hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the pterodactyl
variation in the sicilian defense
specifically it's a line in the hyper
accelerated which the sicilian for those
not aware is e4
c5 knight f3 in the hyper accelerated is
pawn
g6 delaying the movement of the pawn
here on the d file which you'll
typically see in the dragon lines as
well as delaying something like knight
to c6 that you'll see a lot of times in
the sicilian opting for pawn g6 this is
the hyper accelerated typically you'll
see pawn d4 and the main line in the
hyper accelerator the pawn captures on
d4 in the pterodactyl variation which
we're going to be going over today
you'll see bishop to
g7 now the four lines that we're going
to look at in the pterodactyl variation
the first one is going to be pawn to e5
then we're also going to look at pawn to
d5
we're going to look at pawn captures on
c5 those are going to be the most common
and then if you see something
just different
bishop to c4 something i have also seen
preparing to cast on the king side and
striking down on this f7 square so those
are the four versions we're going to
look at in the pterodactyl variation
hopefully you guys enjoy this video
so the first variation is pawn e5 it
makes sense if you look at it it says
okay we want to block the dark squares
this also stops the knight coming to f6
i do think this is a poor move from
white though
black's going to immediately take on d4
and we're going to look at three
different variations on how they can
respond one is the knight takes on d4
the other is the queen takes on d4 and
then lastly we're going to look at pawn
to c3 if they take with their knight on
d4 which is probably the worst of the
three options then we're gonna play
queen to a5 this is check you can see
we're attacking the pawn on
e5
now they have a couple options as far as
how they want to block this
knight to c3 is
pretty bad but we can just go ahead and
take here on
e5 but you can see it doesn't really
matter if they play c3 as well it's
pretty bad just because we also take on
e5 that's
the only two options they have and
that's why that the move knight takes on
d4
is just all around a bad move but that's
what happens if you if you do see that
if they take with their queen
then similar to a lot of other openings
in chess that the queen comes to d4 then
we're gonna play knight c6 gaining some
tempo getting a piece developed into the
game center control as well as kicking
this queen away now if the queen moves
away from this e5 square you can see
that black has the bishop on g7 and
knight on c6 both attacking the pawn so
if you know the queen just comes back d1
then pretty obvious you know black can
just take this material on e5 because
white only has one attacker on at this
e5 square all of a sudden blacks up a
pawn in material white has none of its
central pawns that's going to be pretty
bad so
that that would be a clear mistake just
be looking out for does this queen when
it moves does it still try to maintain
pressure on the e5 square
let's say it does so let's say they play
uh queen to
c5
okay this still maintains some pressure
on this pawn e5
from here i like the move pawn
b6 to attack the queen i do think it
gets a little tricky in this situation
if you try you know pawn d6 to attack it
because after they take we retake yes
the queen comes back here uh but then
you can see from here we played knight
to f6 but we have an isolated pawn on
the d file and
both sides are equal in material but now
we have to worry about just holding down
this d pawn in the center i just feel
like it's easier for white with the pawn
structures with three and three and yes
we're going to have some good king side
safety when we castle on the king side
but i just don't feel like this is as
strong as keeping the pressure up by
playing pawn to b6 now we still force
the queen to move if the queen tries to
stay in the action that's fine maybe
queen two d5
now it's a little bit different i do
think we can play e6 to force the queen
away make queen to e4
and from here
we're going to play pawn to
f6 now it may look a little crazy just
blowing up this king side as far as our
protection but after the pawn takes and
we recapture with our knight you can see
that we're developing all of our
material and we're really forcing them
just chasing their queen away so if they
play queen to a4 we can still castle on
the king side knowing that we're well
ahead in develop now we're not going to
have as much safety for our king but we
should have more than enough
compensation to make up for the fact
that we're well ahead in uh just the
advancement of our pieces so that's what
happens if they take the queen early in
that variation instead of the knight
taking now instead of the queen taking
on d4 they could also play pawn
c3
now remember black has not given up any
piece
of material on the board and they've
already captured the pawn on d4 so
white's really saying hey go ahead and
take this pawn i'm going to try to get
some rapid development out of this
somewhat of a gambit
we are going to reject that and we're
going to play pawn
to d6 here
the reason we're going to play pawn to
d6 remember we're up in material we want
to make sure we have an active position
here now there's two ways that they
could respond they could take the pawn
on d4 they could also take the pawn on
d6
if they take let's say this pawn right
here
well then we're gonna take this pawn and
if they
capture with their pawn now we're gonna
take their queen
if they take our king now we're going to
play knight c6
you can see we're attacking this pawn on
e5 both our knight and our bishops maybe
they play bishop to b5 i think these are
the most logical moves that white could
play pinning down our knight then we
could play bishop to d7
and then maybe bishop to
f4 to try to protect this because again
that the pin is gone now
from our our our knight because we're
now blocking it with our bishop so maybe
bishop to f4 but then we could play rook
to
d8
the white king can't castle so i feel
like this puts a lot of pressure um on
our opponent for sure so this is how i
would approach it
if they take
this
d
pawn now what if they don't take the d4
pawn what if they take this pawn on
d6 well okay in this case i'm going to
go ahead and recommend we just develop
our knight to
c6 i don't think we need to just take
this pawn back right away see what our
opponent does
and from here
they have a couple options one they
could take with their pawn
and so if they take
pawn takes on d4 we could just take with
our queen and everything is fine if they
decide to take with their knights well
now we can just go ahead and take their
knight after the pawn takes now we can
take with our queen
maybe bishop to e3
now we have the interesting move because
our bishop and our queen are both
attacking the pawn so that's why they
play the move bishop to
e3 here
but we have to move knight to h6 and i
like this move because if they want to
go ahead and take our knight that's fine
we can just take with our bishop
but this knight now on the next move can
come to f5 and put even more pressure
on the d4 square but also putting
pressure on the e3 square so it it
really just puts whites in this weird
situation where it's an open board state
right now and they almost have to give
up their bishop pair leaving black with
the bishop hair
but if they don't they're gonna be in a
tricky situation after knight two f five
so that is what we're gonna do early on
if
after bishop two g7 if our opponent
plays pawn e5
the next variation we're going to look
at is pawn d5 i do think this is white's
best option so i know a lot of you like
to watch these videos and see how the
other side should attack these openings
if you're playing for white you're just
playing your normal main line you run
against the pterodactyl variation i
think d5 is the best route now from
black i think the best way to continue
is knight to f6 here
attacking this pawn on e4 more than
likely they're gonna play
knight to c6 and then we're gonna play
d6 and these moves could get uh
you know backwards so you could play d6
and then they played knight to c3 and
then knight to f6 it doesn't really
matter which way you go but i recommend
knight to f6 immediately put pressure on
this pawn e4 essentially forcing the
knight to c3 here and then
d6 now because we have opened up this
light square diagonal here they could
decide to get their bishop involved you
know bishop to b5 i think is fine from
here bishop to
d7 the reason for that is if they decide
to go ahead and exchange that's fine
we're going to retake with our knight
and now we're protecting not only our
knight on f6 but this critical square on
e5
which we only have our pawn right now
protecting that it's being blocked off
our bishop at least is blocked off by
the knight so this knight on d7 would do
extremely
well if they don't play bishop to b5
they have a lot of other options for
their bishop i usually think they are
going to play their light square bishop
to prepare to castle on the king side so
it doesn't really matter if they play
bishop e2 they could play bishop to c4
uh
they could even play bishop to g5 if
they decided they want to
go and castle on the queen side and then
start to throw an attack on the king
side for black all of those options i
think black's just gonna castle on the
king side and continue from there
all right the next variation we're going
to look at is if the pawn takes on
c5 don't really think this is the best
option but you could see it they may
think oh that's a that's a free pawn
we'll go ahead and take that we're gonna
play queen a5 check
and you can see we're already attacking
this pawn on
uh c5 we we can gobble it up pretty
quickly
but they have some ways that they can
mess this up pretty poorly so knight to
c3 in this case we go ahead and take
with our bishop
and now after the pawn takes we can take
this pawn back
now still check so they're probably
going to play bishop to d2 so they don't
lose their rook on a1 and now we can
come back and take the pawn on c5 so we
gained an extra pawn if they decide to
play knight to c3 instead they probably
should just play
pawn to c3 and if that's the case we're
going to go ahead and take with our
queen
right here on c5 now maybe bishop to d3
preparing to castle on the king side
we're gonna play knight f6 maybe castle
and then we're gonna castle as well so
pretty straightforward if they take with
their pawn on c5 we're gonna go ahead
and play queen two a5 uh go ahead and
exchange and then depending on how
you know if they play optimally we just
get that pawn back in material but we're
gonna be castling on uh the king side
and then we can continue from there
the last variation we are going to look
at is
bishop to c4 and this falls under a few
other moves that you could see a bishop
to c4 just seems like the most direct
attack that white has it gets the light
square bishop involved into the game
attacking the weakest square that white
or that black has on f7 because the king
is only defending it right now
when this is the case they play
something besides the normal moves we've
already talked about we're really just
going to be looking to take the pawn on
d4 now i think there's a couple options
obviously they're not going to take with
their queen just giving a queen up
that's usually not the best option here
so usually just taking with their
knights or playing pawn to c3s we looked
at before maybe giving up some
additional material for a gain in tempo
so let's first look at knight takes on
d4
we're going to play queen a5 so this is
something you always want to be looking
at is when you can bring your queen to
a5 check and start to get a strong
attack now
you have knight to c3 this would be a
very poor way to defend this we've
already looked at
the previous version where if they
played knight to c3 we get an additional
pawn in this situation they're actually
going to go down more than that and it
really starts with the move queen c5
with the queen and the bishop now both
attacking this knight on d4 now start to
look at what happens if they say okay
well
let's try to protect this knight you
know bishop to
e3 sure that defends it now the bishop
and the queen are defending this knight
but then we can just gobble up the
bishop on c4 so that's the other threat
that black has if you want to try to
protect all of those maybe
queen to d3
okay well this
protects both of them but yeah again
still black can still take on d4 since
it's protected by the bishop so none of
those are going to go well for
white the other option they have knowing
that pain is coming their way they could
just say okay this bishop is lost
so i'll just go ahead and sacrifice on
f7 which i think is reasonable any time
black
is kind of exposed like this this is
going to go poorly for white but it
seems like a decent effort black's
definitely going to take with their king
here
now if they they still have to worry
about this knight on d4 because the
bishop and the queen are both attacking
it so maybe bishop to e3 here
knight to
c6 attacking the knight maybe there's an
exchange here we can take with our
bishop remember now we take it with our
bishop on c3
we can check the king on e1
so that's why if you kind of look at
this beginning any why doesn't this
knight just move as soon as this knights
move the bishop comes into
c3 and we take so maybe knight takes
bishop takes here the pawn takes and now
queen takes on c3 check
and then after the bishop here then the
queen comes down and takes that material
on c6 so that all stemmed from the very
beginning of that playing knight to
c3 to stop
and after knight c3 then queen c5 huge
mistake instead they really should be
playing uh c3 here to stop that and now
we're going to play knight to f6
remember knight to f6 is attacking this
pawn on e4
and usually the response to that is
knight to c3 develops the piece to the
primary spot it wants to come to control
the center of the board and protects
this pawn but we force them to play pawn
to c3 and so that's why this queen to a5
move is such a good one it forces them
into an awkward position yeah if they
want to play knight to d2 they can it
blocks off their dark square bishop it
blocks off their queen from controlling
the center of the board
my guess is they try to something else
maybe queen to e2 to protect it
okay well from there we could just play
knight to c6 putting more pressure on
the center of the board and then we can
also castle on the king side we're not
going to be castling on the queen side
really ever uh in the pterodactyl
variation just be aware of that but this
is how you would respond early on if
they play that bishop to
c4
hopefully you guys enjoyed this
variation i've had a lot of people ask
on the hyper accelerated if there's
other variations
besides just taking the pawn on d4 and
yes there is the pterodactyl and that's
playing bishop to g7 early on this is a
fun way to play all the dragon
variations i think are a lot of fun but
i definitely recommend if you haven't
checked out the hyper accelerated dragon
i'll have a link at the end of the video
as well as in the description thank you
guys so much for watching if you made it
to the very end would love in the
comments if you throw the number hundred
that just lets me know that you made it
to the very end i'm always curious not
on all my videos
but i do on some of these wanna see if
you actually got to the end of the video
so throw 100 in the comments i just love
this opening so i'm curious how many
people made it all the way to here but
thank you guys so much for watching if
you have any other recommendations this
particular video was from a comment that
someone left uh not too long ago and
said hey can you do a video on this so
if there's one you want me to do let me
know in the comments and i'll definitely
try to add that to my roadmap but thank
you guys so much for watching i'll see
you in the next video